so now let's talk about making sure
you're doing all the variables of the
same time turns and that means we're
doing them where the player clockwise
and counter clockwise cuz if I faced it
if my player coming down the gazebo and
up the big tree if I'm facing the lake
when I turn
that's the ploidy going clockwise but if
I do if I face you with my player going
counterclockwise relative to me
so you're gonna try that and you're
gonna see what I mean so this time plant
your feet this way so the feet are both
facing this spring get the poi going
forwards if you put your right foot out
in front and you turn with me
past the lake and back or up behind the
hips and back I can do all my turns and
it's all clockwise they're going the
rainbow from left to right the golf ball
from right to left you come back to here
if you put your left foot in front your
turn your back to me as you pass your
toes that's left to right and over the
rainbow it's right to left it's the
other way of doing it we want to make
sure you're practicing both ways or else
what'll happen is you'll get really good
at shoulder wheels this way you'll turn
around and you won't know what's going
on so from the beginning you want to
practice everything clockwise and
counterclockwise left to right and right
the left so super easy if you just take
that moment to think okay well what if I
got the lake at the beach I've got the
gazebo and the tree I'm gonna start play
down the gazebo and first I'm gonna put
the right foot in front and practice all
my turns past the lake so that's down
past the toes up over the top in front
up behind the hips behind down behind
the shoulders behind and I can mix this
up any way we want we can go in front in
front behind behind or in front behind
behind in front you can make different
combination
you can repeat golf-ball shoulders golf
ball shoulders we're gonna practice for
up behind the hips rainbow up the hips
rainbow and then shift your feet and do
this exact same thing the other way just
keep shifting back and forth but don't
change the way you're spinning or else
you'll be practicing the same thing you
already practiced so the trick is I
shift my feet so I turn past the beach
with the poi you're still coming down
the gazebo and then I can practice pass
the toes in front over the top up behind
the hips down behind the shoulders and
I'm practicing the counterclockwise
version of all the notes you can make
you little combinations I mean it's
front front behind behind or front
behind behind front so then what you can
do is you can say do you can turn to
your left a couple times so I put my
right foot in front so I can turn down
pass my toes
turn I turn to my left shoulder then I
put my right foot in front again and I
can follow the rainbow over the top
shift pass the toes
step over the top step or I can do a
turn a hind step behind the shoulders
step up behind the hips step down behind
the shoulders or I can go to the right
shoulder up behind the hips step down
behind the shoulders step up behind the
hips step down on the shoulders step or
in front behind the shoulders in front
behind the shoulders up behind the hips
over a rainbow up behind the hips over
the rainbow we'll keep reviewing this
it's gonna it's going to make sense but
for now what I want you to do you're
gonna you know practice for a while
plant your feet the direction
and think practice all your turns past
whatever you got on this side then shift
your feet and practice all your turns
the other way and and then try doing a
few turns to your right and a future in
Sealift and you'll start to see how
making sure practicing all the
variations opens you up to freedom of
movement